let's talk today about virtue signaling
and its cousin dog whistling I get so
many emails about this and it really is
a good opportunity to talk about it this
is these are both terms that are often
used you may have heard this term being
used to criticize people on the left for
their activism or their uh organizing
their efforts virtue signaling the left
are virtue signalers what does that
actually mean and by the way it is
really the right that participates in a
lot of this virtue signaling which I
don't think will come as a surprise to
you at this point virtue signaling means
when you express a moral or an ethical
stance or a political stance it can even
be
in order to gain approval from others
and Signal your virtue virtue signaling
means I express an opinion which I may
or may not really hold which I may or
may not really even understand in order
to signal to others that I am saying the
right things so that they then will have
a better opinion of me
it can take many forms it could be you
post things to social media about your
charitable donations or your activism in
order to Signal your virtue you publicly
Express outrage over some issue in order
to appear socially conscious or that
you're on board or whatever the case may
be now it's really important to
understand that engaging in activism and
expressing values is not inherently bad
that that's not the point of virtue
signaling as a pejorative
when the signals when the actions are
being done when the signals are being
sent
primarily to gain social approval or
status that's when it becomes virtue
signaling rather than simply expressing
an opinion the right loves to say
that it is the left that predominantly
engages in virtue signaling but much
like the right likes to say the cancel
culture is on the left when the cancel
culture is actually on the right as
we've talked about before much like the
right likes to say
that it is the left that is engaging in
voter fraud but in fact it's mostly
happening on the right it is exactly the
same with virtue signaling let's talk
about how the right engages in virtue
signaling conservatives might display
American flags or say I support the
military in order to signal that they
are patriotic and to gain approval from
their peers in many cases they don't
really care about either but they are
using those symbols support the troop
stickers whatever to signal that they
are on the right team when it comes to
those issues or they might say we've got
to stop this cancel culture from the
left the left we I'm for free speech
because they want to appear to be
defending values that are currently in
Vogue even though they neither care nor
understand what the hell they're talking
about nor whose speech is being limited
blue lives matter stickers or
paraphernalia or whatever to show we
support law enforcement in the military
they might not even really care or
understand what's going on with law
enforcement or the military when they
use phrases like I support Traditional
Values I am about real America
you're talking about signaling that you
support conservative cultural norms now
we're slowly starting to get over to dog
whistles which I will get to in a moment
other examples of right-wing virtue
signaling include
um posting on social media about how you
want border security we have to have a
border when you live in you know Iowa
doesn't mean you can't care about
immigration when you live in Iowa but
for many of these folks it is a form of
virtue signaling sometimes expressing
religious beliefs or even going to
church to be seen at church can all be
examples of right-wing virtue signaling
but and this is where we start getting
into dog whistles virtue signaling and
dog whistles are two different things
when we talk about dog whistles we're
talking about coded language or symbols
that have a hidden meaning
that is meant to communicate a
particular message to a specific
audience often there is bigotry or
Prejudice in dog whistle so I'll give
you some examples different ones are dog
whistles to different degrees when
people have been talking about I support
medical Freedom during the pandemic
often what they mean is I'm against
vaccines and so it's a dog whistle more
than a virtue signal in that it is coded
if you're not part of the discussion you
would medical freedom I don't know it
sounds good yeah sure why not but it is
often a dog whistle for anti-vaccine
um talking about often the word Urban
particularly talking about like gun
violence needs to be dealt with for what
it is an urban problem they're talking
about black people okay so Urban in
certain contexts is a ver is a dog
whistle for black and or brown people
um sometimes Law and Order can be a dog
whistle where you're sort of saying well
I'm tough on crime but Law and Order is
also often used as a dog whistle to
support uh racially biased policies like
for example stop and frisk
um America First is sometimes a dog
whistle to White nationalists and others
states rights is one that's been used by
politicians to support policies that
discriminate against minorities roll
back civil rights states rights has been
used as a dog whistle up to and
including support of slavery quite
literally when they talk about the Civil
War globalist can be a dog whistle for
Jews we've talked about that one
extensive before so both virtue
signaling and dog whistling involve
sending a message to a particular
audience the difference is the virtue
signaling is more about gaining approval
whereas the dog whistling is more about
communicating a hidden message to those
who understand the terms so both
important terms to understand
when I use them in the future hopefully
they will now be more clear let me know
what you think of my missing examples of
either that are relevant